you can see Peter on NFL Network's 2020
NFL Scouting Combine coverage kicks off
today at 4:00 Eastern quarterbacks wide
receivers and tight ends just gonna let
you know that I don't know if the buzz
of what's going on here has gotten to
the buzz going on there in Indianapolis
but tell me what the buzz is there first
and then I'll tell you what's going on
in this studio yeah it's interesting so
there's all these quarterbacks that
might be on the move so Dan the buzz
then I get these text in the last hour
that are blowing up my phone about a bet
that was made between Jeff darling I got
I mean it's the only thing anyone's
talking about I just saw four NFL
coaches come together and they're
talking about the bet so that's what's
going on here in Indianapolis you had
got a report from Jeff Darlington a
comment from Jeff Darlington from ESPN
because he Pauly is bet Jeff Darlington
that Brady is going to stay with New
England $1,000 Donna complete
seriousness it is the biggest topic of
this come this CBA talks going on we've
got burrow and tour and all anyone is
talking about in his Brady and good for
Jeff to go on the record and say
something like he said because I'll tell
you I came into this week thinking
there's no chance I was at all on this
one saying there's absolutely no chance
and when it's all said and done that
Brady is going to be anywhere else
because of the way that Robert Kraft and
Tom Brady have lived their lives last 20
years in a symbiotic fashion and this is
almost like a father-son deal I am
Telling You I talked to everyone and
everyone is here
I'm leaving Indianapolis on Sunday and
I'm going to tell you I do not know if
Tom Brady is coming back to New England
it the feeling and the vibe here is that
if it was such a slam-dunk why is it not
a slam dunk already why is it like why
this twisting in the wind and teams are
starting to say hey look it might not be
us but if that team team X does sign
Brady well then that leaves that
quarterback and we might be interested
open and that door might open here
because here's the domino effect if the
Titans of the team that Tom Brady is
talking with and variable in him have
such a great relationship and suddenly
he's a Tennessee Titan 1 and we'll know
that Ryan Tannehill is no longer a
quarterback in the Tennessee Titans even
if Ryan Tannehill is no longer a
quarterback of the Tennessee Titans he
might be with another team which means
another quarterback whether it be
Bridgewater
whether it be rivers might be on the
move somewhere else so Brady is the
first domino to drop the fact that we
got here that we are in Indianapolis and
it's not a wink and a nod like he's
going back to New England it is it is
real it is real and we are entering a
brave new world for the NFL where would
you place Brady if you could if you were
the Commissioner where would be the best
place for Brady if I was the
commissioner if I'm Goodell saying okay
I need to get something going and kick
start a franchise I'm sending them right
to LA and I'm putting it with Anthony
Lynn and saying I don't know if you guys
know each other
but the Chargers we we need some buzz
right now because the river is gone and
we're opening a new stadium with the RAM
and we're going to be tenants it sure
helps us to have Tom Brady on the
Billboard rather than Tyrod Taylor I
just don't see if that's necessarily
happening that's my problem with this
Brady stuff everyone I'm talking to is
saying that he might be on the move
but no one is courageous enough to put
it to a team so whereas the Tennessee
thing might make sense on paper and
you're like all right John Robinson the
GM of the Titans was with New England
when they had Brady and they brought him
in the building and rabl and they've got
Malcom Butler and Dion Lewis and there's
all these connection to the New England
Patriot I can't tell you on the record
or on your show that I have heard anyone
from Tennessee who I know very well that
old organization or anyone from the
Brady can't say yep that's right that's
it go that way so Tennessee seems like a
logical place but I've seen Peyton
Manning be linked to the Miami Dolphins
for an entire offseason they end up as a
Denver Bronco so I will not put my name
on anything yet as this thing is just
unfolded one note Don he was a longtime
agent of Tom Brady all the agents were
here as of yesterday I hadn't seen down
here so I don't even know if he's on the
ground talking to these teams or you
know whatever legal you can't do it
because of tampering but at least having
a cocktail with some of these teams I
haven't seen Don yet so I don't know if
that was conversations they're going to
be enhanced
yeah if I'm Brady's agent I'm not going
to the combine in fact if I want to talk
to a team I just call him I don't want
to do something where somebody goes hey
I saw it's like when Brady was there
with Mark Davis in Vegas and everybody
let oh my god they're gonna the Raiders
are gonna sign Tom Brady you just don't
want that guilt by association of
somebody reading something into it and
and I agree with you it feels like if
New England was going to get something
done get something done before free
agency unless they really want to roll
the dice and say let's see who's really
interested in what they'll pay you or
this Bella cheque actually have Plan B
already in place in his mind yeah and is
that playing with fire like that's the
whole thing because if it was Garofalo
or even versed sitting there waiting I
say okay well I get it or if he had a
free agent quarterback with some history
that he's had with him like he's never
worked with Bridgewater he's never
worked with Dalton he's never worked at
these guys so to say that oh well you
know there's a back-up plan and let's
see Tom Brady test the market it is
Garoppolo has not been in training he's
no longer there right now so it's Jared
Stidham and with one year in the system
and said I'm playing against the Jets I
think for a hot minute through a pick
six and they put Brady right back in
that game I'm not I'm not trying to
fairly sort up the wisest move and yet
the Patriot this could just be a rebuild
if he goes somewhere else because McCord
is a free agent Matt Slater is a free
agent Kyle van Noy is a free agent
Edelman is not getting any younger maybe
this is how it ends
it never ends pretty very rarely to get
the Strahan Elway Jerome Bettis go out
on top thing but should it be weird if
Tom Brady's last game at the patriot was
a loss to the Ryan Tannehill ed Titans
in Foxborough and an interception
pick-six yeah it's not weird
it doesn't feel right it didn't feel
like that was it but who knows and this
is what a great offseason this is and I
say great cuz it's great for me and you
know ya know if it's great for everyone
else but there's real intrigue and it's
not okay where's Melvin Gordon gonna
sign a no offense to Melvin Gordon but
it's not some running back is how many
how about this is maybe the greatest
player we've ever seen and there's
actual intrigue and there's actual
confusion as to where he's gonna be
playing in a month Peter Schreyer NFL
Network host you can see Peter on the
NFL Network's 2020 NFL Scouting Combine
coverage kicks off today at 4:00 Eastern
quarterbacks wide receivers and tight
ends what do you think the Carolina
Panthers game plan is I just talked in
that rule for about 20 minutes on air
and then I was with them long after that
chatted and I honestly think he's being
completely transparent and saying let's
see how these injuries things play out
but
Hoshi's can do and it's one year twenty
million dollars like I think they want
to see as far as in as long that can go
and get a status on his other health but
I don't think they're Russian trade Cam
Newton or get rid of Cam Newton or draft
even a replacement for Cam Newton just
yet they've got the sixth overall or
seventh overall pick I think they're
sitting pretty if they wanted the third
quarterback in this draft which is your
Jordan love or Justin Herbert most
likely but I don't see them going that
route they might bring in another player
to challenge Cam Newton but for one year
twenty million the money makes sense to
say hey let the Li see this when some of
these guys are making thirty five thirty
six million dollars who would healthy
aren't the same caliber players so Miley
on this thing yeah they're in a bit of a
rebuild and keeping gone and it's a new
coach and Joe Brady's a new offensive
coordinator but I would think they at
least want to kick the tires and see
what version of Ken they're getting
before they make a grave mistake and
trade him and see him be the Cam Newton
of old somewhere else which team do you
think goes up hard to get a quarterback
it feels like if Joe Burrell goes to the
Bengals the Redskins are there with
chase young do you have to go up to
three to get the quarterback you want or
do you have to go up higher so no matter
Tricia came out earlier this morning and
said that all the Stafford rumors are
comical really said that the report
didn't come from a verify you know a
good journalist in our world so I
wouldn't trust it like so that was
basically my his way of saying
Stanford's our guy and I don't think he
put that stuff on the record only to
have egg on your face later at no point
that last year that Kingsbury come out
and say I love Josh rose and Josh roses
my there was a lot there to read between
the lines and say okay he's going to
give this ring of world but pirates
probably gonna be number one overall
pick to the cardinal so I think the lion
Turk said occur that the Giants from
what I mean I know that Joe judge has
said he's not saying Daniel Jones's name
because he wants everyone have a clean
slate and week the team that's nonsense
Peter it was it was something it's a
Dana Jeremiah and I were on set we bring
Joe judge on and Joe is great he said
that and it's like
I don't know how how would you receive
that as a player and how would you
receive that he didn't say c'est comme
Berkeley's name so he was like I just
want all these guys on the same equal
footing when I meet them all at the same
time whatever so they're set a
quarterback they know Jones will be the
quarterback they've gentleman's not
drafting another quarterback which goes
to Miami who at five I would think too
it makes a lot of sense like I don't
III think if they sit pretty at five it
makes sense but it also means someone
can come up at three and four and that's
where it gets real interesting I think
that's gonna happen I I don't think you
get to at five
yeah it reminds me of a couple of years
ago true Biscay
I knew the Bears were in on tradition
they they had been quiet about it but it
was starting to leak out and then the
49ers the day of the draft were like oh
we liked risky too in the 49er they
didn't pull the rope a dope or anything
but they basically said we're going to
take this guy unless you give us a pick
and they got a draft pick out of it and
the Bears jump them and took true Biscay
that's what maybe the Redskins should be
doing right here and Ron Rivera said
they're gonna meet with burrow and do it
which isn't exactly you know crazy news
and get the number two overall pick but
it wouldn't hurt them - maybe stroke
that fire a little bit and see what they
can get if it seems as oh gosh we want
to and if we got to get to Lance's
number two let's talk to the Redskins
and let's see what we can do and I I do
like Dwayne Haskins you know I wasn't
sold on him I don't like these one-year
guys but Haskins I think the last month
of the season giving some trying times
perform pretty well and if I'm I don't
know if Ron Rivera wants a veteran in
there he'll have some backups there but
i if I'm Washington I I still need to
see a little bit more from Dwayne
Haskins before I move on I agree I agree
and I think what happens with all this
is you know join Haskins is working in
the building they're going to trot to us
through that building they're going to
trot Joe burrow through that building
there's going to be visits how does the
way napkins respond to that so for Ron
Rivera here we are we're openly courting
or at least meeting with these other
quarterback prospects as much as I want
to get to know them I think part of this
is Ron wants to see how the Wayne
Haskins who last year was not ready to
be a starting quarterback the first half
of the season as much as they wanted to
go to them he had not mastered the
playbook and it just wasn't time yet
DRAM
I want to I think I'm curious to know if
Ron Rivera strategy is let's openly give
an adverse situations indicate if you
have a response and by the time the
draft comes we'll know if you happen as
well and took it in stride and said
great bring it on I'm ready to go I'm
your guy and I'm gonna take leadership
of this team and my first off season as
a [ __ ] well then we learned a lot
from them but if Dwayne Haskins is not
happy with the fact they're talking up
to Limbo he's causing problems he's not
motivated by that that also tells you
something too when you see Jeff
Darlington tell him we want a piece of
him jack is one of these guys just like
a cool guy Jeff is out late he's
socialized think he looks like like the
Mike Silver is late Jeff's got a whole
different deal at the combine I'm
another game I'm watching all 22 film
I'm just breaking down tape now I will
see Jeff I'm sure tonight I will say
hello no no I need you to go gotta go
find him right now he's he's got to
answer this in the next half-hour he's
got to answer Pauly's you know claim
here his charge thousand bucks Jeff
Darlington I'll find him I'll tell your
season on it sorry
thank you do you want a piece of that
bet no no I stay far away that's it
nothing to do with that okay plus you're
on the NFL Network and you probably
can't bet on the NFL Network thank you
thank you
thank you Peter Teeter Schrager NFL
Network hosts their combine coverage
starts at 4:00 Eastern quarterbacks wide
receivers tight ends for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]